reginald b
mckinley the second what's going on
thanks for coming on the program
ah well this is going to be fun this is
going to be fun
that's right let's do this you ready
yeah i'm hella already
oh oh of hello the very bay area of you
yeah exactly
right i was like or hecka you know what
i'm saying like
yep i'm like hecka tight i see what's
going on that's what's going on
grateful to jeanette for making the
introduction
right and you're new to l.a so welcome
thank you yeah i'm a month in i'm a
month into that
life i love it yeah i adore it is the
weather
yeah okay it's the weather it's the
people it's the culture it's the
intelligence the art
the visionary thinking but there's a lot
of other
things that we're gonna make even
better you know in the next protocols
yeah than
what we want to do in the future i love
the excitement like it's always
it's always fun to to uh meet people
when they first get somewhere yeah so i
want to check back in six months later
and we'll see how it
feels i want to check in six months
later and see
yeah see if you had a few run-ins at a
little market if you
like that if you're still like the
intelligence is super high yeah yeah
because you know
la is a dichotomy it's it's a range of
experiences and so
yeah i think acknowledging that is
important so that your expectations
of a place um
don't don't push you places where you
don't kind of want to go
but also so that you can leave space to
be surprised and excited
and so a lot of times you know you're
like oh it's going to be so much better
than wherever i came from but the truth
of the matter is wherever you go is
there you are that's it yeah so where
you go there you are
so you are always where you're at yeah
yeah let's let's let's let's do so let's
dive in let's dive in i love it i love
it
um there's a lot to talk about
in this episode uh diversity equity
inclusion d-e-i
d-e-i is the acronym and this is
it's super fascinating as we were
talking before we
started the program i spend a lot of my
time
on the metaphysical space the nature of
reality
being existence what the nature of
consciousness
is architecting the next generation
protocols to maximize human potential
right and that what was really
interesting was reggie when he was
hitting the ball back with me before we
started he was grounding
a lot of what i was saying in
actual experiential
rubber meets the road examples that are
you know of people needing to literally
feed their kids
very much um stuff like this and so i'm
really pumped to
to unpack this um maybe that's probably
a good place to actually start okay
is as i sort of
understand things from this perspective
of
consciousness undergoing this process of
experiencing itself through this reality
right that there's all these different
flavors of experience that occur there's
flavors of experience of super
duper privilege where there's all the
basic needs are met
and there's experiences or flavors of
life where
none of the basic needs are met right
and
that's sort of how i see it and but
what's interesting is that both of us
are
talking about how to make it so that the
basic
needs can be met right for more people
worldwide that then enable them
to flourish right because my belief is
that
you shouldn't have to
worry about your basic needs
most full stop full stop and i think
we've made people engaging their basic
needs
some version of
success and that's a horrible way that
society has pinned the lived experience
of everybody against
the rich or against uh some other
version of success right
and so i think when you give a
baseline of everyone
can eat breathe live be
safe um and breathe in a very
intentional
way of saying that uh free of pollutants
free of
non-accessibility to clean water free of
to me that's all breathing right yes and
um free of of of
water that doesn't hurt you um free
of free and i think
that's a baseline that we have not
as a society collectively agreed upon as
a necessity and
i so i can't i'm not going to ever
get to a place where it's like well
basic income or
universal health care or something is is
a is a perk
it's not a perk like
you exist so you need to be provisioned
for
yeah and that's a social um
social contract yeah we entered into a
contract to be in this society
and that was a prerequisite as a
baseline
to saying that we're gonna come together
as
tribes people groups and create
something
and at some point that went from a
baseline of the contract
to a success story
no yeah
there's so much more in that success
story
that is just beyond the basic needs
being met the success story is what
happens
after the basic needs are met the
success story isn't meeting the basic
need
that's right yeah yeah well let's be
clear we're
eight months into a pandemic and
americans have received twelve hundred
dollars
eight months the average
cost minimum wage in america pre
pandemic
did not would not afford you an
apartment a two bedroom apartment in
any of the united states research has
shown that
so if i made minimum wage pre-pandemic
i couldn't even even afford a
two-bedroom apartment
in any of the united states and just to
do math there
that sounds like it's going to be
somewhere around 40 hours a week at 10
bucks a week is
7.25 is and it's 7 25.
and so it's going to be you're probably
going to make something around
what like 1200 or 1200 bucks a month or
something like that roughly probably
yeah
and 1200 bucks a month is not is that
kind of nowhere in the us
not in the us can you afford a two
bedroom apartment
and live on minimum wage
that was pre pandemic so let's be super
duper clear here
since this pandemic has started um
and we started calling people essential
workers with a ton of them having hours
cut
jobs cut they weren't able to live pre
so it's not getting much better post uh
and that's
the the working poor the people in
poverty with jobs
we're not discussing individuals who
don't have jobs we're not discussing
people who existed in poverty
pre-pandemic we're not discussing people
who are barely making it we're not
discussing what we still call
the middle class which is inevitably
and yet has not been reclassified
in larger society so
we have a huge problem because we're
1200 bucks in eight months in
we just have a huge problem
i as we as we were
sort of talking before we started i was
sharing with you um a pretty
serious intention of mine to visually
illustrate
a lot of the core concepts yeah and so
this one is in high-level perception in
chapter one i analogize
the tree to the human and so the basic
nutrient needs of the tree
need to be met in order for it to flower
the fruits
okay and the very similar things true
with the human the basic needs as we
were describing earlier
of air water food shelter
love safety yeah right all those things
need to be met
in order for the human to also actualize
a unique gift into the world
right and so this analogy
taken to the level of yes in our
community in our local
like we were talking about l.a we have
our
our little our big problem here in the
bay area with
people that uh have their basic needs
not being met
but also on a planetary level we also
have upwards of almost a billion people
that still
don't have access to clean water and
clean sanitation which is why it's sdg
number six
right and so we are beginning to see
like okay well what happens when
somebody has a tap
or that somebody has something that
they're waking up every day
and finding meaning and doing right and
purpose and doing
and it was interesting that you also
told me you said that
that even having that purpose even
having that thing that you wake up to do
every single day is it's even downstream
of the basic needs being met
yeah yeah and that was also really
enriching for me to
to realize because it's it's that
visceral on even on a on a maslow's
hierarchy of needs
we've been talking about this for so
long and yet our
architectures are not reflecting the
fact that we know that this is the case
people literally when
you gave me the example you're like if
you're freezing cold
and you don't have shelter or safety how
the hell are you gonna do anything
nothing you can't do anything if you
don't even have one
dollar to get a piece of
a loaf of bread at a store right how are
you going to do
anything and so these are the visceral
gut heart feelings that we need to feel
to sort of galvanize us into action
of what to build next to make sure that
all those basic needs are being met
so i i've done a lot of work in the
community and i
i spent tons of years tutoring kids and
working with kids from all different
levels and uh
i understood very early on that if i
wanted to really connect with a kid that
i was tutoring i need to make sure
that they weren't hungry like from a
physical standpoint
yeah i had to make sure that they felt
safe
i need to make sure that they had the
attention
capacity to even be there to be tutored
if i'm dealing with things at home that
you you're not supposed to be dealing
with as a kid
i don't have the capacity to sit here
with you we're as adults we struggle
with that
we have a million things going on all
over the place
and we're asking ourselves how do we be
here right now and most of us don't
really know in a conscious way that
we're asking that question yeah
you know it's it's in a very conscious
way you don't know we're even asking
that question and so
the privilege comes when you recognize
i asked how am i going to be here now
that's a level
of revelation and realization
that most people they don't even bridge
that
right they're just kind of
ran down and i don't know how it's gonna
work
and i'm i'm fighting to stay above water
you hear people say that all the time
and it's so intriguing because
water can bring life or death
yes so it's intriguing to watch how
people engage
life as water
or death as water and so it's always
funny for me because
most people do this when they hear cup
half full cup half empty
i do it when i hear people say i'm
trying to tread water
yeah yeah and i'm like got it i know
exactly where you're at at this point
because half full half empty
there it is in a more
life
even affirming or not way
because half half empty half full cup
wise's
perspective i can't have much
perspective if i think i'm dying
that's fight or flight that's survival
at the core
so when you tell me you're drowning we
have to have a whole different level of
conversation even get you to have
half empty half full you know it's the
same as
pull yourself up by your bootstraps i
need boots
i need straps i need a cobbler
i need leather
i need shoes and i don't think we're
tending to that
and i think we think we're further along
than we are
we're not um yeah
and that's the hard part so when we have
these higher level conversations
i'm the weird guy in a room that gets
what we're trying to do and
also gets that we're not where we think
we are yeah
and by the way this is not a moving
pendulum
it's a very real concrete trackable we
are not where we think we are
so when we say that we're two weeks away
from
most americans being evicted
that's not just to get a response that's
literally people are going to be put out
in two weeks
so congress hacked but i think in
america we take that as
okay they're gonna have a bad christmas
now literally people will be outside
twelve hundred dollars eight months
we can't get away from these things that
are very very very
right here on the ground yeah
and until we actually tend to those we
can't move anything else
which is why i keep emphasizing the
people we have to tend to
what's literally affecting us
i gotta say it's really interesting to
have a
it juxtaposition between the
sort of stephen pinker mainstreamed
argument about everything's becoming so
much
better and we've talked about this on
the show with people like chris ryan
who authored and published civilized to
death
that there's a there's a nuance to that
and one of the
immersive ways to understand that
is the if somebody
has no basic
needs being met
that almost takes them literally back
like a hundred thousand years in terms
of like the state of their consciousness
and that's pretty insane to
think or or from a very technical
standpoint
somebody has a 400 year head start
and if we're talking about america that
would be slavery
will be racism that will be jim crow
that will be
poll taxes that will be the war on drugs
that will be current modern-day policing
um
that would be 400 year head start
we don't have to go super high level
to see how it impacts somebody
and yet people are still pushing through
so this is not a story about a victim
who is not
fighting to live or is not
still building trying to build something
it's about a system that hasn't
reconciled
how much damage it just has done to the
person
that they've done it to or the people
they've done it to
and this is happening more than just one
or two groups this is happening
yeah yeah as a larger hole and we have
to
get to the point where we start to
reconcile
that so this is kind of now a top layer
thing
so when people then come up to us we
have a fair
share more empathy and kindness and our
engagement we have a lot more grace
in our engagement we have a lot more
integrity
in our engagement we have a lot more
we leave space to to listen and we leave
space to
to feel the anger to feel the
disappointment
to feel the despair and i think and i i
literally mean filled it
right um create the space and let it hit
the ground
but we're not necessarily doing that
we're just telling people you deal with
it on your own
and if we want to get somewhere and
that's why i'm so
i'm so intentional right because i want
people to be visible to other people
yeah so then we can truly do work
to create the space we want but we can't
necessarily do that if we can't
create space for people to even be
visible
then see them
just because you create a space for
somebody to be visible doesn't mean you
see them
so then see them then tend to them
their steps yep create space see them
tend to them yeah the way first step
attending to somebody is asking them how
do you need to be tended to
and it's interesting because the tending
is the analogy for
a seat in a garden like we were
analogizing
yeah a moment ago so that's the baseline
of
allyship that's the baseline of
partnership that's the baseline of
even even being somebody who loves the
arts
see it well create space see it
tend to it so it's this
it exists on every level of life in
every part of life and yet we
are picking and choosing how we and when
we engage it
and i think that's what's making it hard
even in these moments
because we're not being as intentional
as we should be
and we're not doing it with the level of
integrity that we should
and integrity doesn't necessarily
monetarily cost
but it will require you to lay down a
bit of your ego
yeah and lay down a bit of your knowing
yep yep to allow somebody else's show to
show up
yep yep it's a great way to put it
so yeah
in this sort of
idea that how could it be that somebody
in the quote
2020 entering into 2021
this year with 8 billion people on the
planet
such massive amounts of planetary
flourishing having met so many basic
needs
can still we can still
as consciousness exploring itself
this in this reality still
have the
insane amount of in a sense it's it's
art it's perfection in its own unique
way
the fact that our creation is so layered
like this
where even in such modern flourishing
infrastructures
there can still be so many people
even in the most developed countries not
even in the ones that are still
developing
but the ones that are developed that are
still
experiencing more in a sense primal
states of
being as you describe in the water
analogy it's true
that you can use water to
sacredly and divinely nourish yourself
where you can feel like you're [ __ ]
drowning and
that's why the st these statistics about
50 percent of americans not being able
to afford a sudden 500
bill 400 400 dollar bill 400
and the
in the it it's it's a
challenge to rise to because you
described this is so
well said too is that to take your
quote you know such
deep knowing that you like you
know like like i had this profound
experience where a couple like on on
saturday
where it was you think you know but you
don't so just like
take the knowing down a level for a
moment
to truly create the container of space
that then enables someone else
that doesn't have their basic needs met
to step into that container of space
and to be seen and to be registered as a
soul
in that space and then also to be
addressed
which basic needs will serve you
immediately right away and how can we
meet those basic needs
right away and i spend a lot of my time
talking about
these macro level inclusive stakeholding
architectures
that biomimic what we see
with mycelium and fungal networks
underground which is a billion years old
and the way that we can sort of make
that in our social contract itself
and yeah sure that's cool alan we can do
that in the next
five years 10 years architect that
and make it so that the physician has a
stake in their
patient and the teacher has a stake in
the student and the
and the community has a stake in their
environment and all these types of
things the environment is a stake in the
community as well
the seventh generation indigenous
principle
but today there are basic
needs that need to be met in the
person's
life and it's such a complicated
multi-layered creation that we're
embedded in
where the idea of well why don't we just
print more fiat currency why don't we
just
distribute that and see if that helps
why don't we
why don't we take some of the
wealth that's being generated on even
the continued
bull market of the stocks and
see if there's a way to distribute
some of those massive earnings that have
continued
through the actual fabric of existence
that makes it so that
like do you want when andrew yang was on
our show he was like do you wanna
do you want a revolution because if we
don't
we're gonna have one because we can't
keep
going like this
so a few things um
just because someone
colonizes or oppresses doesn't make them
first world or developed
secondly um
i think we have a very
hard time conceptualizing that someone
who
also is in need is going to have to show
up for someone else also in need
and so i say that to say
well i have to table that i've already
provisioned
for my needs being met so that i can
make space
for your needs to be met and the truth
of the matter is a lot of times
your needs are not met and you still
need to create space for others needs to
be met
it's not once i get over the hump then i
go back and get you
it's as we're clearing the field
we're all clearing the field um
which then puts a requirement on each of
us every day to do some lifting
you don't get to sprint 20 30 40 50
years down your career
and to say oh now i'm going to open a
few doors you don't get to do that
um so i say that expressly because i
need
people not to confuse the necessity to
show up in real time
with when i get over
i show up in time
um so that's
two um third
the truth of the matter is that this
system can't hold itself
the way it exists the essential workers
are a prerequisite for this system to
work
which are the least paid and the most
important
one two
if you don't purchase things you don't
need
the system can't keep going three
if you don't protect health care
officials
science scientists and have a basic
understanding
of civic responsibility it can't stand
three things we're struggling with
and as much as doctors
and grocery store workers and trashmen
and individuals are happy that you're
calling them heroes and clapping
they really need you to do your part
heavy lift
this is you know this is world war ii
going into a factory and and
building nuts and bolts this is that's
where we're at
people don't really understand that's
where we're at even though all the
statistics show it that
the highest rate of mid-career
millennials
are moving home ever
higher than a great depression higher
than world wars
52 of millennials now live at home
with their parents or family
52 wow
so it's already happened
and that's why i'm so expressly clear on
you cannot wait
until you get over the hump to help
somebody else's basic needs be met
while you're having your basic needs be
met you need to make sure you provision
for others too
because the system is so broken at this
point
that none of us will ever extend our
nets
to help because it's so broken
yeah um again i think we think we're
somewhere we're not
we're in dire straits and i don't
it's almost like
bringing the truth to this makes it that
much harder
it's almost like giving this a proper
lens
is making people say well what do we do
the answer is very simple a lot of times
i don't need money i need resources
so for example
a lot when i was doing grassroots
organizing
early on in my career i understood
something about fundraising that most of
the people did not
and what i understood was that
i go to the person or the entity or the
organization
that has a certain expertise and
resource and ask for what they have
in abundance i don't ask them for what
they don't have in abundance and most
times that looks like physical money
if i go to apple i'm going to ask them
for computers
if i go to kleenex i'm going to ask them
for tissue
if i whoever i go to i'm going to ask
them for what they do really well
in an abundance because ultimately the
resource is what matters the most
and then that's what value is tied to
right and that's why you have donations
in kind
right in-kind donation might have
equaled 100 000 or 30
000 or something because there's a
physical monetary value tied to
these services objects resources being
rendered
but we're taught as for money we're
taught money solves everything
and the truth of the matter is resource
allocation
proper resource allocation people having
a level of expertise and sharing with
community
bartering is is the goal
i sell wheat you sell
yeast she sells salt
he's a butcher we all need each other
that doesn't require money currency has
been a range of things
from the beginning of time sometimes
it's spices sometimes it's fabrics
sometimes it's just your word and we've
made currency
pretty much one thing money or credit
which is money and that's not really
the only way to navigate and so
back to why i said colonizing or
pressing a society doesn't necessarily
make you
developed because in second and third
tier you know societies even
in modern day that we will call second
and thirds here
they understand these basic tenets of
how to build community
and how to have community still function
and run and it's been this way for
thousands of years
there's something very important that we
can take
from that in reference to how we
function in this society that we're not
fully leaning into yeah and we started
uber
with sharing cars not that uber started
that but with sharing cars
um airbnb with sharing houses
uh dot dot shared economy
that kind of became mainstream over the
last
say eight years and really took off five
years ago for real
uh gave some
hint at how i can have an access to
something
and i could ask you for that direct
resource and then you could provide that
direct resource and we can facilitate us
still
working and functioning yeah and i think
we're gonna have to dig into that
what that looks like from a from a
logical logistical standpoint is we're
going to have to have houses merge
now granted during covert it's like
don't have houses merge
well i'm talking about moving together
i'm talking about go get plots of land
or or houses or whatever and put
multiple families back in
into one house this is we had multiple
generations up until about 50 years ago
in one house
we had great grandparents grandparents
parents kids pretty much every household
up to 50 years ago was
a multiple generation household if not a
multi-family household where you had
your brother
and your sister-in-law and their kids
living in the garage and then you built
a house on the back of the land and
so we shifted away from something that
allowed us to really be successful
and shifted towards something that
allowed commun allowed companies
to be successful they could sell more
toaster ovens and refrigerators
if you start splitting those houses up
they can sell you a need for medications
to cure loneliness if you don't have
access to people
and i think at this point we all
recognize with this pandemic
that there was a real opportunity in
having other people in the house
after eight nine months alone if you
lived alone living alone was was sexy
up until eight nine months ago right
people started
getting adoption rates of cats and dogs
and animals went up
people started getting bikes so they
could go out and do leisure activities
and do it with friends safely they
started realizing a necessity for
community to be in-house
not outsourced and so places like
meetup.com
saw uptick dating sites like tinder and
bumble saw uptick
and it's because we understood that
those needed to be in-house
right relationships need to be in-house
and so the hope is that
those revelations will equate to the
next level of movement
of how we tend to everyone's needs and
how we also provision
for everyone's expertise in a said house
i don't need everybody to be a cook i
don't need everybody to be a gardener i
don't need everybody to be
great at child care i don't need but if
i have somebody who's a great cook
and a great gardener and a great child
care then i don't have to worry about
going out to work
i don't have to like it's the house is
tended to
and i think we are
[Music]
and there's portions to that that we
have to work through
um because we see that in some of the
work i was doing around research with
latinos and cover 19
is that especially on the u.s mexican
border where i was located
there's multi-generational households in
most households
so you at least have the grandparents
parents and children in the household at
least
and so what that looked like for covert
19 is a lack of resources
um or lack of access to healthcare
resources
if covid hit because you now have
susceptible generations and generations
that are kind of perceived to not be
susceptible which will be younger
generations
all intermingling every day so when you
send out messaging
you have to have the whole house buy-in
as opposed to just
one or two generations in a household
well in larger cities you might not have
to deal with that
where you have the split where all the
young people live together all the
elderly together all the
right you have these these more spread
out
intergenerational dynamics
so there's there's pluses and minuses of
how you have to build it out but you
have to build it out
you have to start having these
conversations so my answer is
the other way where you have
intergenerational households
um and then you have a cultural
understanding
of what's necessary in order for the
household to stay healthy
view it as an organism and everyone has
to buy in
but that's kind of where we're at as a
collective hall
this also in so many ways
takes me to what i
have we talked about this before we
started
and you were mentioning it a bunch
throughout the last segment
in this this is chapter 7 the sorting
algorithm and high level perception and
it just follows the saying that goes
you keep the baby and you drain the
dirty bath water
and if you do it for
indigeneity and you do it for modernity
and you drain the dirty bath water in
each and then you uplift the baby and
merge them together into one
and that has a massive
that synthesis has a massive
contribution to the future
architectures that we're talking about
that maximize prosperity for everyone
because
you mention this very
sacred principle of
that service to other mentality whether
it be someone in the family circle
or whether it be someone in the
community that
principle and that's a very in many ways
mimics what i'm talking about with the
mycorrhizal networks
underground 95
of plants use mycelium for a two-way
resource exchange underground
so it's a very service to other style
mentality a very symbiotic exchange
mentality
whereas like purdue pharma and the
opioid crisis
is not like that yeah there's
many examples of these styles of
extractive
behaviors that are serviced to self
self-dealing behaviors
which we're moving away from and so we
need to
visualize those talk about them and
build the future instead
you you're saying that you believe we
are moving away from those
in well the well the flux
happens at this there it's all
simultaneously
evolving in the perfect creation that it
is so meaning literally
at the same time that we're moving away
from those perverse incentives that we
talk about
we're also experiencing
perverse incentives continuing to be
created
and that we have to shine the light on
the dark
to show people what we want to move
towards instead
that's better but we have to architect
that that light
i just also want to say one more thing
on this point
which is that this was something pretty
recent that ray dalio published
which was the sort of big macro level
cycle about what's
currently occurring on a planetary level
which is that
the united states is following
a very economically
strenuous moment which is what you've
been sort of indicating for us like
like we think we're doing fine but we're
not and
whereas that's why we're currently going
through
like when lehman brothers collapsed in
2008 the subprime mortgage crisis hit
what happened was
satoshi nakamoto published the bitcoin
white paper a month after lehman
brothers collapsed
it enabled the decentralization
revolution in the last 12 years although
it's not to the degree where everyone
literally has a crypto wallet
everybody in the country and everyone's
frictionlessly exchanging value
and we have a barter economy running
simultaneously like you were describing
which is a very indigenous style
principle
we're not there yet
but we clearly see that fiat is
absolutely disgustingly broken
and that we're currently experiencing
this
down cycle due to things like that
and other aspects of exclusive
stakeholding
whereas china in a sense is more on its
way
up but is also going to experience
similar
economic issues if it doesn't get its
[ __ ] together
because it also has hella vulnerable
people that need their basic needs met
and it also needs to figure out how to
inclusively stakehold everybody
all one point almost five billion
of them which is which is five times our
population of about 330 million
so the whole planet in a sense is
undergoing
an awakening simultaneously especially
in these more
economically quote of course there have
been massive
issues in the last 400 years like you
were describing right
but in these areas where there is so
much wealth
we've we're we're undergoing more of a
like holy [ __ ] if we don't get our [ __ ]
together
we are going to experience downstream
effects
that we don't want to experience we
don't want
those we we don't
want venezuela we don't want
the insanity of what's going on with
another style of of pandemics recessions
bubbles exploding uh and you think
that's
what americans feel well
it's it's difficult to say because um
you i think you're spot on that a vast
majority of people in the country
feel like we described where the 500
bill 400 bill 50 cannot meet
that's i think how people feel right
because that's at the core of existence
which i've been extremely vulnerable on
the program as well
in being completely clear that that we
are also in that same position we are
literally on a monthly position where we
can't afford that 500 400
bill either which is insane because you
would be like well
i would wonder why some artist
entrepreneur
that is trying to make a media show
around consciousness and maximizing
potential
can't afford that either well you get
lucky
in 2017 you score a big gig you're able
to afford
equipment and then from there it's
literally just a monthly
cycle of taking everything you make in
like ad revenue and just putting that
right back into paying all your
subscriptions and bills and all that
kind of stuff
but you know you do it with the
intention of thinking like
well the show by the time you get to
2025 is going to be
a lot more financially able to sort of
handle
and support but you know you put me in
the ballpark
of kind of that same thing where i want
to create
more space for people to feel registered
and for them to say these are the basic
needs that i need
that i need met at the same time that
i'm
undergoing the same process with people
that have
beyond my basic needs be met so it's
like the teacher student
and the teacher-student relationship as
people say in the spiritual community
is very similar with the financial
ladder that exists right now
whereas i feel totally good today
with even seeing somebody that doesn't
have ten dollars and giving them ten
dollars that they need to get a meal
but that i still am gonna at the end of
the month
struggle to pay my utilities and i'll
still have to make a call to somebody
and i'm grateful that i even have
somebody that [ __ ] believes in me
to that degree that will be like alan
here's 500 bucks pay your 300
utility take the 200 bucks and do the
other things that you need in order to
sustain what you're doing because we
need you in the world as well
yeah and that's some [ __ ] insane [ __ ]
that we have people
like that the conversations that we're
having on the show
that are still barely also getting
through
this quote you know filter literally the
thread
through the head of the needle situation
and i appreciate you sharing what you
just shared because for so many people
especially with you being a white male
they don't think that's your experience
and i think they need to know that
there's a lot of us
in this boat and if if there's a hole in
the back section or the front section
we all go down yeah and i think that's
the disconnect
is that everyone looks at everyone else
and thinks that everyone else is fine
and that's why i stand in this gap as a
bridge and say
oh we're all not fine and i need us to
get
just gutterly honest about what it will
take for us to just get
you know level yeah
just level right um
and i think that's the disconnect that
we're not
i love that everyone is optimistic
a lot art i love right i love that
everyone's like let's do this right
but i also need us to be super super
super
um realistic too not even realistic i
just need us to be
really plugged in
to the realities to these very viscerals
that we
have that affect us so that we can then
show up for each other
right i want to be
in a place where it's not viewed as a
negative
to have somebody authentically say
i need help yeah yeah
help is just help it's not a it's not a
weakness yeah
and we've been taught in a society that
it's a weakness to need help
specifically as men yeah yep
suicide rates are amazingly high
depression is amazingly high
specifically with men because we're
taught shoulder it you better figure it
out
and that is counterintuitive to us
being a fully fleshed out human being
having none of the emotional language or
the emotional space
or the logistical space
or the opportunities is literally
stifling
and i think we have to start to have
these really really really trans
parent conversations around what
masculinity
has not given us access to in the
traditional sense in a society
and then we need to figure out why
really negative
non-healthy things were tied to us
being men and then we have to start to
renegotiate
those things because if we don't we're
gonna
keep creating these cycles right and
that's why i'm so happy that you just
shared the way you did
because what you showed
is that by me having this level of a
transparent conversation
it creates a space for you to
authentically honestly show up about
your journey
and know that you're supported in it yep
so then the next step
is honor what you just heard yes thank
you for sharing
yeah speak to what you just heard i
heard you
yeah affirm what you just heard
we're all in this i did it in real time
right and so it's it's we can all do
this
but it takes a level of of
empathy and intentionality
to show up in these very authentic ways
and i think that's what's hard
because especially when someone like me
shows up at the doorstep
it's gonna get raw if i knock on your
door
it's it's a it's a transitional period
if i knock on your door
um more importantly you're probably
gonna knock on my
door and if you knock on my door i know
you're in a transition
you're going from one place to another
you're having a conversation
that's outside the fray
and so that means then for me that i
then have a responsibility to hone
in on what my
role is in your journey
and then it's like okay now let me be
sensitive to that
and not be unaware
of how we all impact each other
at the bare minimum if i can't help
i don't want to hurt yeah so my goal is
help but if i can't help don't hurt them
i don't know your show just kind of took
a turn
it's probably not going to work i love
it
not at all it's it's perfect the
creation doesn't have
accidents the creation only has
synchronicity
art beauty and everything that's
supposed to happen
and so you know
evan passing along the intro to jeanette
jeanette passing along the intro to you
it's all meant to and you expressing
yourself exactly the way you are and me
our souls dancing in this way is exactly
how it's supposed to unfold
agreed there is
there's um
there's something that's deep within me
that
sees uh two things that would like to
share which is that i'm open i believe i
mentioned this on the show with jeanette
as well
is that there there seems to be
potentially one of the ways
like planetarily that people are
starting to in a sense
categorize um the
individual and the collective is
something along the lines of that
the idea of the individual
needing to step up and
take sovereignty for themselves
and their lives and their dreams and
aspirations and their family and take
burdens on their backs and
responsibility
and then there's this collective side
which is the collective says
look at the social fabric the social
fabric
needs the basic needs to be met in order
for the individual to take said burden
on their back and achieve these
goals and all this type of stuff and it
appears as though
that that synthesis
just like we saw in that sorting
algorithm example
is ultimately where we need to go and
that
there's there's sort of that okay
and then there's a and i can go ahead
and bring up
this which i think is also
helpful to an extent it's sort of the
idea that
we we very frequently when we
talk about this architectures of the
solutions
that we view the
8 billion humans on the planet usually
in a hierarchy of wealth
yeah but rarely rarely
do we ever view the 8 billion humans in
a hierarchy of enlightenment
right because if you do you start
getting some weird things
right like some people that are
the richest in the world have some of
the most egoic
levels of consciousness right and then
you're like
oh [ __ ] because then if that's in the
u.s congress the u.n general assembly
fortune 500 ceos 2200 billionaires out
of these people
if we're talking some of them literally
have some of the most egoic levels of
consciousness
we are in a that's a really bad top-down
process that's occurring right okay so
we have that and this is why
trickle-down economics does not work
just throw that in there keep going and
so there's
this and then there's sort of the other
side of things which is
well okay mr
reginald and atlas here talking on the
program well why is it that you have
people that are in the quote
international poverty
of less than two us dollars a day across
the planet
why is it that they can also be if you
say that
they don't have their basic needs met
why can why are they
at times also so happy how can they be
so
happy without a cell phone where they're
constantly looking at
instagram how can they be so happy
if they have to take a jerry can gallon
to a well
to get their water instead of use a tap
and so all these very
weird questions also bubble up around
what true needs need to be met
also simultaneously in order for people
to feel
in a state of peace in a state of
happiness in a state of
also flourishing now my sort of
ball might have a very simple answer for
that my ball to you
and then oh like this my ball that i'd
hit over to you about this would be
i see it having to happen from both
sides at the same time
where you where we meet the basic needs
of more people around the planet
and let them in a sense
actualize their gifts into the world so
meeting the basic needs that we've been
talking about throughout the show
and the architectures that enable that
social fabric to flourish
more abundantly but at the same time i
don't see it just from the grassroots
and i'd like to hear if you see it this
way too but all those people that we
listed at the beginning
in terms of that are at the top of this
wealth hierarchy two and
2 200 billionaires on the planet 225 000
ultra high net worth people which is
30 million plus in in us dollars in
assets
535 people in congress u.s congress 200
plus people in the u.n general assembly
fought fortune 500 ceos i think that
from a top-down
perspective that their enlightenment
their enrichment their true knowledge
embodied
of the other as the self in that oneness
that non-dual consciousness will also
spur them from a position of power
to make that social fabric more robust
so it's a grassroots and a top down that
happens at the same time
do you see it that way how do you see it
so the front part of what you said
um was the question of
how are individuals who live
different than me happy and the answer
is
they don't standardize your existence
as the priority existence they
standardize theirs
and what that literally means relativity
what that literally means is
from a very clear brown
theoretical moment whiteness is not the
standard
yeah don't have cultural myopia as wade
davis has said yes
more specifically eurocentric ways of
navigating the world
is not the standard and because
typically what happens
is we walk in and say this is what we
believe
as somebody who's bringing divine
um whatever it may be
to the table well we're the
we're the ones who were civilized how
did you standardize yourself
um we're the ones who know god
so are you the only ones who know god
we're the ones who have
this is that a necessity for this
environment
but we say it is so
the idea is to stop centering yourself
as the space that the universe revolves
around
and because other individuals understand
that at a
kind of core level and live out of that
space they also too can have
success and happiness that's not tied to
any standard that's yours
but that is tied to their standards of
how they choose to exist
one so unstandardizing eurocentric
thought processes um and colonizing
thought processes
and globalizing thought processes is the
easiest way to acknowledge somebody
else's
understanding of their own success
because then
you now based on their standards
and you start to embrace and understand
their culture
and then you get to exist with them
from a place of gratitude as opposed to
a place of judgment
of what is or isn't barbaric one
two um
the idea that
somehow trickle down economics is going
to work on any front i just don't think
is real
um and that's including with
enlightenment of
the most well to do on this planet i
don't think those trickerdone economics
will work either
it's not a lack of information that
exists
it's a lack of
ingesting it it's a lack of
awareness to what that means from a
standpoint of solely
this does or doesn't benefit me and
what you're asking for is that the
individuals who have the most access to
power
become selfless
and the reason you're asking that with
your line of reasoning and thoughts
is because you understand inherently
that they're not selfless
and that's why we're having the problems
we're having because you need a society
that functions to be based on
individuals having a balanced approach
and you acknowledge that a large group
of people do not have a balanced
approach
which is leading us where we're at
um how they rebalance or if they
rebalance
is going to be up to kind of how this
shakes out as
mr andrew yang said do you want a
revolution because it's on its way and
nobody can kind of tell you what that
looks like
because historically revolutions can be
in the sciences or in the arts or in
literature or in
the academy or it could be in the
streets it could be a war it could be
in the form of suffragist it could be
there's a million ways to
have a revolution and i think the next
sets of revolutions that you will see
will be more based on evolution versus
revolution
and it'll be groups that are very
specific to causes
calling to have
things tended to specifically
i think the idea in the moment of
generals is kind of gone
generally i want freedom right generally
i want equity
now i want not only seat at the table
i want access to first dibs of what's
coming to the table
and i also want six other people
at said table that represents larger
society
that's what i mean right i want freedom
move that
to this is what freedom and equity looks
like
here's how it's manifest
here's the ask are you providing
and i think you're seeing that i think
you're seeing that in very actualized
ways
at this point and i think that's the
discomfort
because the more specific you get with
the ask the more
whoever has to provide that is
understanding they're saying no
when you're not very specific it's like
i didn't say no to that
i'm not this then a third i'm not sexist
or
bigoted or homophobic or racist or
or elitist or
dot dot fill in the blank right whatever
that may be i'm not that
um but when he asks very specifically
let me be free in these ways
and then you push back on those you now
have to have conversations about
what you really are standing with and by
and i think that's what people are being
called specifically to deal with
you no longer get to skirt past and say
well i only care about this topic
i'm not asking about that topic i'm
asking about this topic
but i don't want to talk about that well
we need you to talk about it
and that's where we're i think
people are having a very hard time
sorting out the
specifics that they're being asked
and i think they're trying to
do the best they can to hold on to
really unhealthy
thought processes and ways of engagement
without addressing
why they do what they do and how they do
it
and i don't think anybody's letting them
up their feet are being held to the fire
and you gonna have to address this and i
think that's
the discomfort i think the discomfort is
that
here's rubber here's road it's meeting
friction
friction now to some people that's
negative friction to other people that's
what's getting down the road
oh but it's all friction and it's just
how you view the friction
and i think that's what you're seeing
right now in a very
here down way yeah
yeah i i viewed the entirety of
the creation as a beautiful artistic
expression
that's occurring even though there's a
tremendous amount of friction
the creation continues as a vehicle
moving down the road and
we as the conscious agents
in it get to experience it through
all of the different tastes and flavors
of it that we were describing where you
either have
you know everything from all your basic
needs met and self-actualized
self-realized all the way down to none
of the basic needs met
and so when
you speak about it it makes me
both realize that
i care so much about
having other people undergo the process
of
maximizing their well-being and just
making less suffering if that can be
just a daily thing to do
is just figuring out how to make less
suffering and meet more well-being
on a planetary level that will get us
far
just that in itself and i believe neil
degrasse tyson said something around
those lines as well as one of his
philosophies to life
and i just one of the things that i
don't
know yet for sure but that this
is what the feeling is and the more that
i look at economic simulations the more
that i realize that we need to be very
very vigilant with what we're doing with
with what's go with what's going on
let me get the graphic back up for
what i want to say okay it should come
up now
there it is all right
because in this moment that ray dalio
illustrates
and that the essence of what we're
talking about regarding 50
of americans not being able to afford a
400
bill we need to be
careful
because when the rubber
hits the road
and it is hitting the road right now
there are
and it has been hitting the road but
especially right now we're in a very
fun part of the creation that's
unfolding
it's a very intense part
that the
the trajectory space
which can be visualized like this
you know this is a this is a scale
invariant
representation of a bayesian cloud of
probabilities meaning that whether you
think about this from an individual
level or you think about it from a
country level or a planetary level that
you have the possibility space that's
infinite in your tree of possibility and
you can
go more and more towards maximizing
well-being or you can
go towards accidentally more hell and
more suffering
and my small claim
would be something that as the u.s is in
the position that it's in
we may think that we know
what the best ways forward are
in that tree of possibility
but almost surely
everything as i was saying on an
economic simulation level
as well that it's
not a universal basic income
that meets basic needs as much as a
universal basic stakeholding
a ubs instead of a ubi does
which means once you illustrate the
scenario for us which we've talked about
on the program
so many times is that when you gather
the global elites at the world economic
forum in davos when you do that yearly
what's what's going on is you got a
bunch of people
7.999 billion people on the planet
that are like smelling the dinner that's
being served there
that are like why how are we inclusive
stakeholders in the dinner that's being
served there right now
and so what
appears to be a
solution that is clearly more on the
side of well-being
and maximizing flourishing is a
universal basic stakeholding
which actually makes people inclusive
equity owners of the planet's trajectory
and it drives them dividends of wealth
that is being generated so it's not just
getting the income
itself but it's getting the income and
being an actual stakeholder
that then gets paid off over time plus
that is able to
pass that along to the next generations
so it it seems like there are
more clear but
at the same time the what i'm talking
about regarding
tokenomics and mechanism design and
decentralization and smart contracts and
ethereum applications and everything
that i'm talking about right now
is very clearly something that's like
one year two year three years
like that is going to be implemented in
the social contracts
which are more long-term but what today
makes somebody that doesn't have access
to
their next meal what today
enables them to achieve their next meal
and that makes it so that they can wake
up the next day
in safety in shelter and
maybe considers then their own unique
individual purpose and how they can do
something every single day
that drives value to themselves
and the community immediately
universal basic income
universal health care access to proper
education
funding for access to proper education a
flip
of funding to education is how you
actualize that
so the schools that have been funded
based on taxes
from high yield places or locations
take that money give it to the lowest
kind of funded schools
and flip it for a bit in a very
actualized way
um super revolutionary but
that's a easy way to start to rebalance
this very quickly
um
you can look at proper housing
that is sanitary has a high level
of humanistic design to it
and housing for everyone you have enough
housing specifically in america that no
one should be homeless
you have enough vacancies that no one
should be homeless enough vacancies that
people that are under housed
can be housed so proper allocation of
housing
dignity to the work you do so not only
giving people a job
not having them underemployed but also
having them have dignified
integral work that gives to
and feeds their civil and civic
obligation
to be part of a sad society tending to
the emotional state
of individuals through access
to universal therapy and
mental health access um
independent of universal healthcare
so that that's a a solid tenant and
foundation
um viewing a range of things
through the proper lens through
universal mental health
access as more of addictions
as opposed to crimes tending to policing
and social justice on
in reform to the judicial system
so going in and overhauling it and
expunging records
and getting people out of jail in prison
and giving them their lives back
in actualized ways through universal
basic income
universal housing proper education
access
if access to college funding for college
funding for geds funding free community
college
um free four-year university free
ivy and above university based on
earning potential and so everything that
you're saying is
spot-on for the immediate and so then
the question that then
would would be asked would be that do we
follow
a as we described earlier this roaring
continued bull market that's occurring
even through the the pandemic is there
like bernie sanders proposes a a half a
percent
tax on all wall street transactions how
do you
fund the market is not tied to
livability of humans
and that's been proven are we talking
like 1 000
100 billionaires out of the 2200 that
exists on planet are here in the united
states
do we how do we take what
well like to be very clear 10 million
dollars from each
well well let's let's be clear because
that's so to be
super clear yeah you start taking
funding from military endeavors
okay so the military-industrial complex
is about uh 700 billion
us dollars you start taking money from
from
you re-allocate funds okay
redistribute funds from military okay so
that's also redistribution this is this
is extremely
important is what we're talking about
policing so you redistribute funds from
policing
to pay for the mental health aspects so
now what that looks like
is instead of case in point instead of a
police officer showing up to a mental
health check
or a suicide check or something you now
have a police officer and a mental
health professional
show up that's beautiful and so that's
how you pay for the universal mental
health aspects
it's not it's not necessarily defunding
police
it's reallocating funds to expand how
policing happens
you make a community policing
how you pay for education how you pay
for health care
and how you pay for universal basic
income is
getting rid of tax incentives for
corporations and organizations
now not fully getting rid of them but
making sure that people
pay their their portion in their hall
and those three things will be tented to
by making corporations actually pay
taxes
so we've literally everything i've
discussed is taken care of so let's
let's
do these three one at a time okay so
there's this quote that we have in high
level perception that we say a lot
today the most civilized countries of
the world spend a maximum of their
income on war and a minimum on education
the 21st century will reverse this order
nikola tesla
and so of course there are some nuances
to this to what we were talking about
but
um generally speaking it
sounds like the very first because
there's this long list of items about
meeting the basic needs today
it's fantastic agreed
by vast majority of people i think
then the next step is
the optimal allocation of funds to set
process now 700 billion dollars
per year allocated towards the
military-industrial complex
now there's potentially
several billion dollars that can be
taken
from that and allocated towards what we
described
then there's also the the
uh amazon google
apple facebooks uh
walmarts um of
military corporations and policing okay
those are the three places but
okay well okay yeah and so so there's
this massive like
the fortune 500 companies let's say that
somehow managed to skirt taxes
every single cycle through the best
lawyers and the best
loop no no they don't manage to skirt it
it's built into the system so just get
rid of tax incentives and breaks
see you can't skirt something that was
built in that you don't even have to
skirt
we've ingrained it so deeply and even
with this last administration
they gave even more incentives to
companies and organizations they gave
even more tax breaks
so they don't even have to hide at this
point they don't have to
actually do anything but just follow the
law
so what you've ultimately done is you
made sure that the law is covering
companies and organizations in a way
it's not covering individuals
sure okay so just
scale back okay tax incentives scale
back
tax breaks reallocate funds that you
then collect
towards the greater good of civilization
but
yet retain the incentives for
entrepreneurship retain the incentives
for
bringing a transcendent north star into
the planet
at the same time and like but let's be
clear right now
the people skirting those incentives yes
yes i just wanted to also maintain that
part of it
right but like let's see that that's
what happens so often
and we have we have to like get really
clear yes yes
that the nuance so that's what we were
doing yeah it's very
interesting because a lot of people who
have a problem with this this incoming
administration's
um yeah it's tax plan it's clear it's
clear
it's like well you don't make enough for
it to hurt you
but like what if i do one day well then
let's talk about it then for now
let's do this for the greater good so
so the money sources again military
industrial complex first
second is corporate taxes and then third
is redistribution of police
funds which is usually the biggest
budget of any city
locality you're missing the municipality
okay so the biggest budget
of usually is is usually of a local
local
local county municipality are we talking
10
you know you have some you have some
counties municipalities that have 33
percent of their budget
or higher 38 of their budget go to
policing
and they have five percent go to
social services and they have 10 percent
go to education
i want spot on i also want to say this
is really important what you mentioned
earlier that i just want to make sure
resonates deeply in people's essences
and hearts because it
it it passed mine quickly but i wanted
to anchor it
which is that what you do is you bring
mental health professionals with police
to those visits very much that we're
talking about which i love that
i just want to say that that's yeah
that's super clear
beyond conception like that one is like
duh
like yeah yeah exactly because well i
mean i think that's that's where
the goal of people making sure that you
can't
reallocate money is to position it as
some extreme
far right or far left thing the truth is
the most logical thing to do is to take
funds
hire new people or properly pay the
people you have
and then have them go to handle the
things they have expertise to handle
it makes only sense if a police officer
goes to the academy
for a very short amount of time and has
no experience dealing with mental health
yeah
anything yes then we should activate
somebody to make sure that
the greater good of the larger
communities being served yeah yeah
so what's the problem let's talk about
like
tomorrow like let's let's say that we
are literally
given like okay sure 700 billion dollars
we're gonna take five billion of it and
it's we're gonna have to figure out
which part of the military-industrial
complex gets a 5 billion
decrease but what are we literally
saying that
that that 5 billion how does it
get disseminated to the
330 million americans based on
a basic income distribution a
universal health care i really
appreciated that mental health
perspective that was really
awesome and there's
these other components that that you
list
as meeting those basic needs so
if we could you know tomorrow undergo
this process of taking
you know 5 billion from the 700 billion
in the military industrial accomplice to
start
and then maybe we even leverage people
like the big tech
organizations and their corporate tax
evasions
to attempt to also get another 5 billion
potentially from that
and leverage their tech their due good
day because they have one whole day per
week
that they dedicate for their employees
to do good on that day
um and so maybe we even galvanized their
hours and their engineering talent
so now we have their hours their
engineering talent and 10 billion
dollars you know what do we do i think
you're
being presumptive about the moral
leanings
of people i this is why i believe you
need to legislate
in some version of community
buy-in um because that
last part you just said about their
do-good day per week
you're assuming that's used for
community not for self and i think we
can kind of track this
from a research standpoint and see that
it was used
solely for self um even in how it's
typically pitched right that it's like
these
hours are for you to do other projects
outside of the job
at said tech company so that it gives
you the opportunity to imagine
and innovate so that you'll be better at
your job at sac tech company
that definitely didn't say that you got
to go in a community
sure sure and spend that time in
community that said do
outside projects that that could be
strumming a guitar
like the mental like the perspective
that the corporations sometimes use in
order to
work on the mental health of their
employees and and maximize their
well-being is because they will
literally be
better for the bottom line of the
company itself yeah rather than
i am literally spiritually so deeply
care about your essence that your
well-being is prioritized
period like not about yeah but i mean
baseline of that is is
it's really simple they realize that
some people were on
you know company hours working on side
projects
so they said listen an incentive to have
you come
over here versus our competitor with
your
expertise and skill set is we'll give
you some time to work on a side project
that we know you're already going to
work on
and they said oh great incentive that's
better than
a pool table in cheetos
i'm in how much time do i get you get
15 of your time here with or 30
of your time here whatever the
percentage is that equates to half a day
a week
that you work on side projects yeah it's
about yeah it's about 20 percent or one
day a week yeah
something right and it's like okay great
that's a great incentive to have me come
from
the competitor to you right
now granted let's be very very clear
that this is happening
in top level organizations not down
yeah and then let's play let's play the
scenario more which is like okay let's
say we get the moral leanings of the big
tech companies on these days
their engineering talent let's say okay
we won't play that scenario because it's
less
it's less likely to happen okay okay but
let's say we get the budget let's say we
get the 5 billion from the us
military-industrial complex
and then we get the 5 billion from
corporate tax evasion
and that we take those 10 billion
dollars and then we have the
basic income for tomorrow literally and
then the basic health care needs
the mental health needs all these things
that you listed um
for a moment ago so how do we distribute
the 10 billion dollars
into the social fabric well i mean it's
local up and so we've always we've
always known that what does that look
like
um i mean you could look at the model
that they have in stockton california
where they
tested out the basic income um with
i believe a thousand residents for a
year
and saw that it worked it injected into
the economy
it gave a security net to the families
that were on it
it allowed them to actually pursue
passion projects
with just an infusion of 500 to a
thousand dollars a month
on top of whatever they were making
right and
so to recognize that means that okay so
if we implement this kind of across
lines then it'll be that much more
impactful so i think recently maybe a
few days ago
you saw a tech ceo step forward and give
i think 15 million or something to
support
uh a city or a town's universal basic
income
um endeavors and
that i would love if if individuals who
had access to that
really bought in and said every year
i'll commit this much
to this and i'll write it into our our
bylaws now
this is a committed rather the company
stays or goes
right this is this is similar to a
pension you know
and then most of us don't know what
pensions are because we're a little too
young and
we weren't raised in places where
pensions were a baseline um
but back in the day a pension was you
work 20 30 years
for a company like a boeing or a
honeywell
and you got a gold ring and you knew
that you're going to be good the rest of
your life
whether social kicked in or not because
there was some safety net
from the time you served there most of
us will never see a pension
that are millennials now because it just
doesn't kind of exist
in our in our psyche of
you know organizations that we work for
they rather kind of pitch other things
to us than
a pension understanding that a lot of
people kind of head out
after a few years in the current
structure of how you build your career
um but similar to that it's like
writing in like a pension so even if the
company leaves
wherever this is still coming to the
residence
that helped support it even if it was
as workers or just supporters
in a sense that they tended to you um
this would be very helpful in places
like the appalachian mountains
and coal country in oil country where
they already
lost industry um but when industry was
there they were the main supporters of
it
right and they should have some version
of a pension
from the what they put into this and
that's part of their their argument is
that well these companies came in got
stuff out of us and then we didn't get
much out of you because you left
or you weren't defunct or you and so
there's nothing left and i'm just
sitting here with black lung or
or you know another another pandemic or
epidemic that's based on
on medical or whatever it is right
and so i think we have to be very very
clear that
whether i work for your company or not
if you're in my town i've supported you
and if that's the case then you have an
obligation
to also support us long term too um
yeah yeah that's but that has again this
is
it would be great for people to get that
inherently and say we're right now into
our bylaws but we're not seeing that
happen
so not to say that you could legislate
that in but not to say that you can't
not to say like the you there are some
mechanisms in the levers that could be
pulled that haven't been pulled
that may not be the most popular but at
the same time we got to get to pulling
and we're not doing the most we can to
pull the levers
to have us have the maximum impact that
we're aiming for
and i think that's what is most
important for us to really
hone in on following this is
this is super duper duper duper duper
rich
um i'm loving this yeah this is it's
just
well because you're you're you're
exactly
jeanette was spot on you're exactly
i mean reggie is exactly what
this program needed to
anchor in our long-term
maximization of human prosperity
in today's basic need architectures
um so it looks like
you know something it appears like it
looks something like
you know maybe like this
because i love the visualization
component and i'm noticing that the
i'm just quickly noticing that the red
itself this can be maybe like
green yeah green is better because it's
the dollar sign
and then this gets you know this gets
you funneled over
and funneled over so yeah so it's
something like
let's see if i can put this into into
the view yep there we go all right
so from what i understand from our
conversation
there is this is tomorrow this is like
today's
you know today is even better today's
what we need to do
now this is the now now now this is not
the
you know five-year architectures that we
kind of talk about this is now
so now we have the input of the 700
billion dollar military industrial
complex we take something like
5 billion from that the corporate tax
evasion that
has been happening for the long time as
reggie was talking about it's literally
built in
to the fabric today we take five billion
from that
we output that into today today
into the universal basic income into the
health care and mental health as the
output to meet the basic needs
of more people yes go ahead so yeah you
could add a three
under that would output or output um
that would be tended to by corporate tax
would be education oh yeah okay
and number four would be housing yeah
okay yeah because there's
there's plenty we've been talking about
that on and i mean
education yeah from pre-k
to through college yeah there's
yeah burning pre-k through yeah yeah
right there's enough wealth for there's
enough so literally you could just draw
your arrows
from number two and housing and housing
and you add those two to the list that
is tomorrow
and number four would be housing and was
there another input that we were talking
about oh yeah the
municipalities right municipality
reality because
the healthcare and mental health if you
want to draw an arrow
for number three and input it would be
reallocation of policing so if you grab
your
i blue how you i love how you visualize
so
right reallocation of police budgets
local police budgets
local police budgets and if you
draw arrow specifically
to mental health exactly a green arrow
specifically to that that's exactly it
yeah
and so um we don't know exactly what
that amount is but that it's gonna
look like yeah like that exactly
and that's what you were talking about
with having a mental health professional
tag along to every single one of these
but also have mental health
professionals not only for the community
but also for the police
so you start to implement requirements
for police officers
to have mental health trainings
and such because community policing at
its core
is meant to uplift and and
bring a level of safety to
said community and what we're finding is
communities are not feeling
safer with police in them
so there's a very easy way to have
police officers be integrated better
into community now
not only police back in the day police
officers lived in the communities they
served
well we're seeing that that's not the
case as much anymore so if we're not
going to have police officers move back
into the community
we need to have better mechanisms for
them to engage the community they now
serve that they don't they no longer
live in
yeah and that's where mental health
professionals come in
because there's a lot of skills that can
be given around
and trainings that could be required
it's no different than an attorney
attorney has to do
re-up classes every few years a doctor
has to go
take re-up classes every few years
so there should be ongoing running
working knowledge
with police officers as they go on in
their career
becoming really mental health advocates
i would like one day to see that
ex-police officers transition
into mental health fields when they
retire
so then they take all that knowledge and
start to give it back
to younger police officers and start to
give it back to bring
a language to other industries
about how policing mental health
emotional intelligence
and community engagement go together but
that could happen if you
actually have police officers engaged in
mental health
uh trainings throughout their career
yeah and that's the most tangible
visible way that you'll see it's
actually happening yeah that's that's a
huge one
i i totally agree that's that's huge and
it also speaks to our show's polymethy
we care so much about people becoming
polymathic the learning from multiple
disciplines becoming more
multidisciplinary and synthesizing
wisdom
and mental health should be something
that is police
are trained in just like doctors should
be trained in nutrition and eastern
medicine practices and and and mental
health and mental health
so let's yeah exactly so let's listen
mental health yes yes
let's let's take a dive into uh into
summarizing so this is i want to just
juxtapose this so
this is my you know as i talk about a
lot on the show this five-year style of
universal basic stakeholding
infrastructures so to juxtapose this
with what reggie's been teaching us
about which is literally
implement this now so this is tomorrow's
execution we need to implement this now
to maximize the basic needs being met of
everybody on the planet
on the input stream we have on the left
number one military industrial complex
out of the 700 plus billion dollar
budget take 5 billion
corporate tax evasion rather than
enabling that to happen take five
billion out of that as well from these
wealthiest corporations in the united
states also the relock
reallocation of local police budgets now
that one specifically goes directly to
the mental health like roger's talking
about
and then on the output side the other
things that these 10 billion plus
dollars can go into is this universal
basic income
health care education housing
so a very very strong i think
breakdown of the core essence of what we
were
um talking about in the last especially
segment of the program of
and actually since the beginning which
is literally meeting the basic
needs of people especially here in the
united states the proper architectures
to do so
and i mean a lot of this can also be
brought so real quick
yes education is very important from the
standpoint that
if you're going to have this society
transition
into the next levels where individuals
get the skill sets
necessary to do the jobs of the future
education
and re-education and access to education
is going to be absolutely necessary
yes yes so it's not only for individuals
who are aging out of their current roles
or that are that are getting older it's
for individuals that are career
switching
at any stage and i showed you this
graphic as well we're talking which is
literally the massive as andre yang
tried you know two years ago to come in
and begin
uh showing people that the labor force
upskilling needs to happen
in order to make sure that everybody
has a deeper inclusive stake in not only
the daily
meaning and purpose and drive to to to
accomplish
um and and especially that this sort of
this kind of plays on that long-term
five-year universal basic stakeholding
infrastructure that i'm talking about
because um to even though tomorrow we
can get
ubi and healthcare and what's needed um
in the long term you're right that we
need the education i i'm really glad
that you
that you point out that with so much
salience because
and it's um it's sort of modern day i
don't know if you know like you know
montessori method maria montessori the
style of like follow the child like get
the basic needs
figure out what the child's passionate
about and follow the child's interests
and synthesize science and spirituality
help them be scientists and engineers
but also have them be
mystics and have them be philosophers
and artists and be
at play at the same time so this is kind
of like the education
all the way up through you know the
community colleges and beyond
um right yeah well i think it's one of
those things where
we have to look at if we could
meet these other needs it's easier to
tell individuals
hey now that you have the space go back
to school
right let's get a new set of skills and
let's bring a new industry to a new
region or area
and this is very specific to uh
rural remote and suburban america
that i'm discussing right because it's
industry leaves
new industry needs to pop up and exist
what does that look
like how does that look and a lot of
times it's not only
having companies choose an area or
region it's having an area or region
choose a company
and the way you do that is by having a
certain amount of skilled workers
already in that area
so the company says this is prime soil
to bring
industry to case in point you have
spacex who just popped down to
brownsville texas which is a region that
i'm
my family's in and they pop down there
because it replicates
cape canaveral and houston yes in
reference to
the exact same kind of offerings and
reference
with it being the launch sites and all
this stuff but also the region is prime
for them to pull directly from the
region for skilled workers
and from the state for skilled workers
there's also a reason that tesla is
moving
to austin um because there's already
primed
industry of tech that exists in the city
of austin and so
i think a lot of times it's chicken egg
egg chicken
and you can help right so if you get a
number of skilled workers
in industry in said space you can start
to pull companies and organizations
that way to you um and that could be
based on
and there's a range of ways that you can
implement this but
it can work um secondly
around now after all of this as very
sheer basics we have to get people back
to dignified work
yep we have to get people back to
dignified work and i emphasize dignified
work
because there has to be a source of
pride in the things that you do
so that you can continue to do them at a
high level and i don't
want us to look at under
performing individuals as underprepared
individuals
yeah because a lot of times i might be
fully prepared and just hate it
it may not be dignified it may not be
integral it may not
speak to a level of depth of engagement
or responsibility that i would love to
offer to the world yeah
and we say we'll just be happy to get
what you got
well you go back 100 years individuals
who could
choose the farm they worked on and they
could farm
or tend to what they want to tend to and
take it to market and sell that
i don't necessarily want to just
be here i want to do something that that
speaks to me
i want to grow i want to nurture i want
to sew i want to
whatever that looks like in the modern
world right like that's
that's the most tangible way to say in a
model what does that look like
and so figuring out what that looks like
and how to make that immediate
because the next thing is the argument
that always comes up which is the kind
of final thing i'll touch on
is they look at the outliers and say
that's the whole
and they'll do this by saying well look
at the people who got the universal
basic income
or got the stimulus check and stopped
and got out got out the market for a job
come on stop it you know that wasn't the
masses but that's what you're pitching
so that you don't have to do anything
else well all these people
got more unemployment than they got
working so they don't even want to go
back to the workforce
stop it if anything that demonstrates
that the workforce needs to re-up and
get to the
to a proper place your basic
minimum salary and earnings
need to match what you gave
during the pandemic right at the bare
minimum
and the fact that you took something so
much
more shallow as the teaching and the
learning from that
is representative of how far we have to
go
because you don't want to do right by
people
right so and i i literally mean you're
not aiming to do right by people
because if you saw that the basic income
that you gave during a pandemic was this
and you realize that people were not
earning that outside of the pandemic
you should have said we have to change
minimum wage
we have to change this way to change
that's what you should have said but
what you said instead is
well we're not re-upping that because
they're they're not going to go back to
the workforce to get jobs that pay less
you did math to determine that this is
what somebody needed per month
and you recognize that large swaths of
people were not making that per month
and then you blame the people who didn't
make that per month
for not making that per month and made
it their fault
when it's something you could have
changed as a legislator
as an elected official as a commissioner
as a city official as a county official
you could have changed this
there's nobody stopping you from saying
well we're gonna have people get paid
more
there's a lot and we're learning through
this pandemic how important
localities counties and states and
municipalities are
we're learning very clearly how
important they are we're learning how
important a governor is
with this pandemic we're learning how
important mayors are
with this pandemic so let's let's act
like we now know
now that we know how important they are
let's
hold their feet to the fire to be of
more service to us
because before everybody focused on
federal
what's the president doing what's
congress doing what is your city
commissioner doing
what is your local elected official
doing what is your school board member
doing that's what you need to know
because that's what more immediately
like that graph you made affects you
what are they doing with your money
allocation what are they doing with your
resource allocation
what are they doing for you and so i
hope that's what people get from this
yes but to answer that in a more
immediate way that education
from pre through college will help
because with the proper
level of funding and education and a
proper
investment in civics and proper
honest history then we will see how
how to build upon what did
work and to make sure we don't repeat
what didn't
but right now we're getting a real clear
civics lesson
during this pandemic and a lot of people
are failing this test
because a lot of your elected officials
don't know what their powers are
a lot of people are failing this test
but we got to do better as a larger
whole
thank god i had civics in school
but i know tons of people who didn't
thank god i cared about history and
politics
but i know tons of people who didn't so
i'm sitting here primed in a situation
where i could talk about how things
interconnect
in a way that at least 70
of americans can't and that seems like
an amazingly high number
but i think that's the low end i think a
lot more americans cannot fully flush
out
how this works and that's dangerous
yeah because that's how you keep that
small percentage of people
navigating the large percentage of
people when they don't know
how any of this works they're just in it
yeah that's
spot on and it goes back 2500 years to
the greeks
talking about the crucial importance if
you're going to have a democracy of
being educated and at to the degree that
you talk about is uh
is spot on um
and you as we form these unique
souls into the world it's important to
retain their youthful creativity as they
become knowledgeable about how to be a
really strong
uh democratic citizen in the social
fabric
because they're the ones that are going
to be thinking about these solutions
in the infrastructures and to not stamp
out
their creativity with sort of the
archaic
styles of funnels into our incumbent
infrastructures
and quite frankly i also think that what
why nixon called uh tim leary the
most dangerous man uh because tim leary
said that
when people take entheogens when they
recognize the kingdom of god within when
they fully unleash that
um they don't funnel into the uh
archaic uh consumptive processes
of the media and they don't fight the
wars and they don't
file into the corporations and the
incumbencies
and so i think that the the revolution
that
like multi-disciplinary association for
psychedelic studies
maps and many of the other
uh entheogenic unleashings that are
happening on the planet through these
natural secretions
are simultaneously here to catalyze that
awakening from both the grassroots
education democracy level
as well as from a top-down level as
you described there are people that
awake and say that i want to take some
of my millions of dollars and put it
into these ubi
scenarios that are happening and to
prove that that is actually efficacious
for today's basic needs being met
i think the episode has been
ridiculously just
beautiful of a synthesis again with so
much of what you're
doing on the rubber meeting pavement
with a lot of what i've been
conceptualizing as schemas around the
nature of our existence
and i think that meeting the basic needs
is where the
the beauty of it is where we meet
and overlap in so many ways and that
that's what gives us all of the
downstream gifts
that we all want to see we all want to
see the more beautiful future
that our hearts know is possible for
everyone to be in that state
of where their basic needs are met
they're able to actualize gifts they're
happy
they're healthy they're well they're
flourishing with them their families
their communities
the planet we know that that's at the
core of so much of what
we care about and that you illustrate
well for us
what needs to happen today in order to
get there
so last thing i want to share is we need
the individuals who are conscious
and privileged which you may be
conscious about privilege and you may be
privileged without conscience
they all need to activate in very big
ways yes there's a huge responsibility
for all the influence that you have big
and small
to be activated towards correcting the
ills
of individuals who may need your help
you have a personal responsibility
and i'm saying this because i come from
a lot of these communities where it's
we do tons of yoga and we're very
realized in the same third but we don't
talk about race
we don't talk about socioeconomic dis
disadvantagement
or disengagement we don't talk about
under
employment we don't discuss
educational disconnects we don't discuss
that's not acceptable anymore you have
to get in the game
like as uncomfortable as it is as
great as it feels to be like one day the
world be utopian
that ain't today in the most layman's
terms
that is not today today you're in the
trenches
and you are looking to the sky but you
are
lifting and digging with your feet in
your you hands
so i don't want anyone else
to go floating off yeah get in the game
i love it and it speaks so deeply to the
self-realization of that
one infinite creator and consciousness
exploring infinity
anchored the realization anchored in the
self-actualization of the feet
being grounded on the ground the hands
being dirty
in meeting the basic needs in
architecting
on a moment-to-moment basis the more
robust fabric
that maximizes flourishing we talk about
this so much on program it's just such a
good
it's such a good back and forth
dialectic on this one it
yeah i think you have to change the name
it's a meeting basically
right or something like you got to
change the name of this whole segment
because yeah
i don't think we touched on whatever we
discussed
we talked about we talked a lot about um
the meeting meeting basic needs is a
good way to maybe
call this episode meeting basic needs
because that's what we
talked about but that has so much to do
with equity the equity
side oh very much of what but i also
think that
a lot of people look at doing a series
of of
things through a singular lens and i
think there's a necessity to understand
policy climate
community and private
like in in what i mean private industry
private sector
and you need to figure out how those
intersect yeah
and i don't see a ton of people doing
that because a lot of people don't have
exposure
it's it's this is way way
way way more about meeting basic needs
and also
especially at that core the uh that
youthful education
that's so deeply um needed to become a
healthy
prosperous citizen in the social fabric
i mean
so spot on reginald b mckinley the
second
that's me that's you that's me this has
been something we didn't
honor such a pleasure thank you for
coming on of course
thank you this is good it's such a
pleasure
holy cow yeah you are
you are the man like i love it i love it
jeanette you
jeanette holy cow what a video
right now you know you gotta get your
jeanette we can hear we we can also hear
jeanette in the uh yeah she can take a
video we can we can
and we can video we can also hear you in
the in the background which is on the
mic
but we'll we'll also take another one of
these after we
wrap the program yeah
i love this this is so nice
ow i love it
there we go i love it thank you this was
so good thank you for coming on the
program what a pleasure
we would love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below everyone let us know
what you think about this episode on
meeting basic needs
on the best way to possibly you know get
there
right literally right now with the
things that we talked about
on the show uh i wanna show it one more
time for people as well right here
on how to best architect it literally
today
literally right now on what we need on
the input side
right now and where we want to put that
on the output
side right now yeah and how to keep in
mind those
more longer term inclusive stakeholding
infrastructures as well
uh it's basically the the way we get
there i love it
and let us know your thoughts and
comments below and episode love to hear
from you
also uh check out the links in the bio
below right now
we have uh reginald's linkedin profile
and soon we'll have
additional links as well there for you
um and
also have
more conversations around this theme um
like the video
share it with people subscribe if you
haven't already especially with people
that
need share with people that need to hear
from that rubber meeting the road
perspective on meeting the basic needs
of people around the world and what that
can maximize especially here in the u.s
share that share that this has been a
very great nuanced dialectic on it as
well which is
precisely what we aim to feature here on
the program so
um and support the
artists entrepreneurs scientists
engineers spiritual leaders in your
communities
and around the world that you believe in
you can support simulation our links are
in the bio below
to help us continue flourishing with our
goals as we
vulnerably shared on the program it's
extremely important
for us to continue um
with our mission and vision and purpose
here in los
angeles and that's all folks thanks so
much for tuning in we love you very much
go and build the future manifest your
dreams into the world the now
the power of the now yeah yeah this has
been awesome thank you all right thanks
everyone
thanks reggie lady guys